and thank you again for joining today
welcome to the first session on
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases in today's session
we will speak about the emergence and
development
of bioinformatics and infectious disease
research
we will discuss what infectious diseases
are
and how they can be characterized from a
data perspective
specifically next generation sequencing
data
we will also show several examples for
bioinformatics analysis methods
that are used in pathogen diagnostics
viral
evolutionary studies antiviral drug
discovery
vaccine design as well as the
characterization
for emerging drug resistance to do so we
will rely
on the tbinfo analytical platform
designed for virology studies for those
of you who have still not completed
their registrations you will also get a
good overview of the omixlogic
infectious diseases bioinformatics
training program
interested in effective utilization of
bioinformatics for
infectious diseases immunology and
microbiology
for all of you joining us for the first
time my name is deepsha biswas and i am
the omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interactions with
thousands of users
that are part of our bioinformatics
community managed by
prime biotic over the past couple of
years we have seen
participants from all over the world
join our training programs
take online coursework and utilize our
big data analysis
tools in various research projects let
me start by introducing our company
and collaborators to share with you
details about the upcoming omics logic
bioinfomatics
for infectious diseases program and
explain
how the training resources we will
discuss today
can be used effectively for research
independent learning or as a structured
training program what we will discuss
today and throughout this program is a
result of hard work by an amazing team
led by company co-founders
dr alfred tober and dr leonid brodsky
dr tober comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise
in oncology immunology and biochemistry
of inflammation
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support of many
research projects and initiatives
that support data science training and
applications in medicine dr leonid
brodsky
is the director of the turbo
bioinformatics research center
at university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics
and bioinformatics and over the course
of his career has developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data
analysis under his leadership
the tauber research center started
collaborations with research teams in
such universities as the university of
california san francisco
institute pasture julian university and
many others where research labs are
working
on cutting-edge research projects
studying viral and bacterial infections
and designing novel drugs and vaccines
to treat and prevent
infectious diseases now
before we move on i wanted to invite
everyone to come and join two of our
groups that we have on linkedin and on
facebook
so dr mohit if you can please uh share
the links in the chats
so if you are new to your community we
would
urge you to come and join these groups
where we keep sharing
updates regarding these programs
as well as any other updates from the
industry
so please join us here
in the first session of bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
we will talk about next generation
sequencing
to introduce the program to you
we have our program mentors and let me
start by introducing them to you
dr harpreet kaur is a certified omix
logic trainer and expert
bioinformatician
who will guide the sessions and assist
participants with projects and analysis
during the program
her area of specialization is in
genomics and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is a romix logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr majumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over
10 years of experience working with
industry
and academia elia brodsky
is our co-founder and ceo at buying
biotech in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with industry
and academic partners that are applying
multi-omics integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology and clinical applications
i will pass it on to elia to talk about
the increasing role of bioinformatics
and data science
in infectious disease research and
introduce you to the types of challenges
data analysis data organization
integration and visualization can solve
for biomedical research projects
over to you elia
thank you
so let me start this by asking you
a few questions before we begin so the
first question i have
is what is your current level of
education i know that we have here
participants from all over the world
and what we are interested in is not
just conducting these
online programs but also developing a
long-term
relationship with a community that is
interested in application of
bioinformatics in a variety of
domains so let me ask you this question
if you could please
put your response in the chat box
so number one what is your current level
of education
1a high school 1b undergraduate degree
1c graduate degree 1d postgraduate
degree
all right great excellent thank you very
much
what we will do with this information is
we will collect it and analyze it for
our future programs
we understand that those that come from
high school or undergraduate degrees
need a lot more
preliminary training and so we will help
guide you to that training so that you
are familiar with the terminology
and are able to do the analysis
effectively for those of you that are
graduates
and have postgraduate degrees we welcome
you to
benefit from the more advanced materials
and so we'll help shape that
curriculum for you introducing some of
the more advanced topics and projects
for you
let me ask you another question what do
you expect from this program so this is
the first session in our bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
and today we'll talk about next
generation sequencing
what kinds of questions and what kinds
of projects you can do with different
types
of topics that we will cover
so what do you expect from this program
by joining this program you can learn
about bioinformatics in general
sense you can get familiarized with
infectious diseases and some of the
challenges that are being
researched there you can get an overview
of bioinformatics and virology so a lot
of people join this program to
learn about coca-19 and other viral
sequences
and then 2d apply bioinformatics to a
research project so if you already have
a research project in mind the data set
what would that be okay excellent so
it's great to know that a lot of you are
interested in
a combination of these and that's fine
so really what we're interested to
understand is how well
can you can you utilize some of the
resources that we'll cover today
specific projects that you have
a true passion and a drive and a
motivation to
address so excellent thank you very much
for answering these questions again we
will analyze this information for all of
the participants
of this program and will be interacting
with you
some of you have seen and you will see
at the end of this session that we have
multiple
options to register for the program some
of it includes interaction with
a mentor and so this information is
critical for a mentor to be effective
in those types of interactions
okay so let's talk briefly about what
infectious diseases are and how are they
different from non-infectious diseases
an infection is essentially an invasion
of an
organism's body tissues by
disease-causing
agents or pathogens their multiplication
and the reaction of host tissues to the
infectious agents and the toxins that
they produce
so the infectious diseases are also
called transmissible diseases or
communicable diseases
and they are the result of an infection
the pathogens include viruses bacteria
fungi parasites all of them have sub
categories
but all of them have the key pathogen
that is causing that infection that's
why they are transmissible and
communicable because the pathogen could
be spread between
individuals non-infectious diseases are
chronic diseases so they cannot be
passed on
unless they have a genetic background
and they're caused by such factors as
environment
nutrition lifestyle and genetic
inheritance
the world health organization recognizes
four main types of chronic and
non-infectious diseases
cancer cardiovascular chronic
respiratory diseases like asthma
or chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and diabetes
but we will also talk in the context of
this program about
many pathogens that actually contribute
to some of these
non-infectious diseases so we will see
that there's actually
a good relationship between both of
these and it's not such a clear cut
now when we talk about these pathogens
one of the key ways that they
harm the host is by replication so the
replication of pathogens in the host
leads to a major
interference that starts from membrane
disruption
as in the case of viruses and release of
toxins as in the case of many bacterial
pathogens
also bacteria and
they colonize different tissues
interfering with
the function and so many of these
interferences
include modification of molecular
biological pathways that are designed to
fend off intruders
and signal to neighboring cells and
organs
of coming danger and so you can see that
here you can see this is actually
coveted 19
replicating and infecting the host cells
you can see how much of that virus
is coming out which means that inside
these cells there's an
active production of these virions and
here you can see
how uh some of the uh viruses
and pathogens are also introducing
uh specific signaling um of toxins
that actually cause different types
of cell death and apoptosis including
oxidative stress and other types of
stresses
bacteria oftentimes damage
the membrane and also
cause secondary passenger uh
pathways to be modified and modulated
and so you can see that
a lot of this leads to scarring and
tissue
uh damage for example some of the
pathways are not even
uh kind of what the virus or the
pathogen causes
uh they are the response but because the
response is so strong
it can have a major impact and long-term
impact on the organs
so in the context of this program we'll
take a look at some of these
processes identify such molecular
pathways and try to understand
the relationship between the host and
the pathogen
now how can the host protect itself
the host can fight infection using their
immune system so here
you can see a few gifts that you can
easily find
on the internet and these gifts really
show you
how the immune system responds so here
for example you can see a white blood
cell chasing
a pathogen here you can see
what those blood cells look like as they
seek to identify
different types of present antigens that
they would be signaling that
this death is under this cell is
undergoing infection
and so some of this is related to the
immune system here you can also see
an example of bacterial growth and the
result of
penicillin now penicillin
kills bacteria this is actually produced
by hhmi
this little gif and you can see that
what it essentially does
is it just breaks the membrane of the
bacteria
so we will talk about some of these
processes and some of the interactions
we know that the host microbiome has
some
antibacterial producing bacteria
and viruses we know that
there it's a complex system and so the
major
way that the host can fight off
intruders is the immune system so we'll
learn about that
and the major way that we can help
get that immune system activated are
vaccines
but we'll also talk about antibacterial
and antiviral drugs
and how do they interact with the
different pathogens and how do the
pathogens respond
to some of these viral antiviral and
antibacterial treatments
developing resistance so we'll talk
about some of that and importantly how
to identify
such trends in data now vaccines have
been discovered a long time ago
as far back as the early 1800s
and today of course we hear a lot about
the kobit 19 vaccine
but really we're talking about a
renaissance in vaccine design and
development
a completely new approach that is driven
by molecular knowledge
now overall vaccines and antiviral drugs
like antibiotics
or antiviral drugs and antibiotics have
been
very very effective health measures but
they come together with
other epidemiological control measures
or health measures
that were very effective in reducing the
number of
death incidents from these pathogens
these types of pathogens so for example
you
can see here a brief chart this is the
rate of death
per 100 000 population per year and you
can see how
that rate of death has been spiking
around pandemics but overall
what we have seen over the course of the
20th century from 1900s to 2000
we have seen a major maybe 10
or more fold reduction in death rates
as a result of control measures and
ways to disinfect
so reduce the number of pathogens in
water in the environment that we live in
and you can see here for example the
first use of penicillin
the vaccines introduced and then
the number of people getting vaccinated
so all of these measures have been
very effective however what we know
today
is that in the 21st century this
trajectory essentially changed we've
seen a number
of pandemics or epidemics
that have caused us to lose confidence
in the measures that have been so
effective right so we've seen
the flu coming from swines the flu
coming from
uh avian flu right so h1n1
all of these deadly viruses like ebola
and
of course now we have covet 19. you can
see how
uh this vex this rate of death from
covet 19 has been surpassing
some of the other major causes of death
that are not
necessarily a result of pathogen so it's
very
important to understand that this
trajectory is now putting us
into a new age for vaccine design
antiviral drug design and antibiotic
approaches to treatment that combine
molecular data
and analysis tools that allow us to have
a rational approach
to answering such challenges and so
what we'll talk about in the program and
in today's session the focus of today's
session is going to be on next
generation sequencing because this major
type of data
has completely revolutionized the way
that we
understand pathogen so up until
this type of technology was introduced
our understanding of
pathogens was mostly driven by our
ability to
observe in using a microscope how these
pathogens were produced
and a lot of that has to do with
isolating pathogens and studying them
in the lab now we know that many
of bacteria and viruses
are very difficult to handle and study
in the lab and isolate and also to look
in the microscope obviously viruses are
very difficult to look at in the
microscope
so the sequencing technology has really
changed the way that we understand that
genetic material
that can characterize the communities
that they live in
and the way that they interact with the
host so here you can see
a brief overview of what types of
insights we can get
from this type of sequencing data so we
can
understand the population structure and
evolutionary history
we can look at specific sequences for
detecting and characterizing strains of
these outbreaks and we've seen
in the previous pandemics of ebola and
the coronavirus that we're in
right now how this type of data has been
coming out
almost in real time allowing the
international community of scientists to
start
asking very specific questions about
where is this virus coming from
how is it changing over time what can we
do
to try to apply previous strategies that
were successful
to this current challenge of course we
are talking here also
about other types of more in-depth
questions that are not diagnostic but
they're really to understand the
mechanisms
that these pathogens utilize to infect
and overcome host responses
and this is important because this basic
biology
this basic science has really driven a
number of translational projects that
help us
make these vaccines and antiviral drugs
and antibiotics
much much more effective because we
understand the logic
and can design within parameters that
save time
and save effort that is troubleshooting
and kind of trial
and error based so as a result of this
kind of data this kind of genomic data
we now understand and can study
effectively
the interaction between the type of
virus
and the type of host response in stages
we can
look at time course of disease
progression by looking at
viral modification and host response and
measuring that host response in very
specific types of
data we can also look at different
types of variation at the genomic level
to understand
resistance to antiviral drugs and
evasion from such treatment over time
that's also an important part of it
we can also really characterize how the
process of disease
happens giving us insight into protein
protein interactions
and routes for intervention and here you
can see
also a characterization of the immune
response over time
and really this ability to characterize
the response over time
is of course very useful for precision
medicine so actually
infectious diseases is one of those
areas of precision medicine that has
been
tremendously improving as a result of
genomic
data and genomic medicine in general has
been most effective in addressing
such pathogens as we are discussing in
this program
now it's not just the sequencing data
right together with the sequencing data
there are some other types of data that
are important to incorporate
to be able to ask such questions and
answer them definitively
and so we'll look in the context of this
program
at omics data different types of onyx
data or multi-omics data
that includes dna variation host gene
expression
measurement of protein abundance
composition properties of microbial
communities
and all these are very different types
of data that we all need to know
how to effectively study and mine for
patterns to understand such host
pathogen interaction
so let's look at a couple examples of
how
we can deal with data and what kinds of
data sets we will be dealing with
to be able to ask such questions so the
role of bioinformatics which the
name of this program obviously is
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
so the role of bioinformatics and being
able to study
viral and bacterial pathogens
is to kind of put the infectious disease
specific infectious disease into the
context of data
and so as researchers are able to access
process analyze and visualize these
kinds of high throughput data
they are able to start asking questions
and answer them definitively making
assumptions and testing those
assumptions by evidence provided in the
data so you can look at
viral genomics and evolution immune
response and identify biomarkers that
help detect those
and then also microbiome and infection a
relationship that is very fascinating
because
our whole view of the way that these
pathogens
uh kind of exist and live together in
communities
is changing because of this ability to
sequence data and understand
what is really going on in real life um
so we'll talk about this in a section
in in a second but first let's talk
about this one major way that
bioinformatics is
changing our understanding of the
microbial world so
the original uh appreciation of microbes
uh
as i mentioned was a result of seeing
these
pathogens uh in a microscope
and eventually today we have so much
data
about these pathogens that we're
starting to ask completely
different questions about the
communities that they live in
and so today we have a realization that
uh these are communities or whole organs
that actually
have not only a specific pathogen but a
whole community of pathogens that
coexist and
form the specific relationship with the
host
because of their composition and so we
can talk about things like
the microbiome and specifically the
virum
as well which is where we can understand
all of the viruses present in a
particular
environment so uh we
know that the virum the studies of the
virum are in their infancy because it
has only recently become possible to see
the birom in large sequence data using
bioinformatics tools that can detect
relationships between viruses
despite its extreme nucleotide sequence
diversity so
we're not talking about a single
pathogen we're talking about
many variations of the same pathogen
that is very dynamic right
they are changing all the time now
the size of the mammalian environment is
not even known
although our own cells are outnumbered
about ten fold by our bacterial
microbiome
the number of viruses may be even
tenfold higher
and human feces alone contain about 10
to the eighth to 10 to the ninth
viruses per grams of billions and
billions
of viruses and additionally the
mammalian birom is continuously updated
to rapid evolution of viruses
and through exposure to viruses in the
environment or in other mammals
so as a result because of the
differences in the viral and the
microbiome in different communities
we see that interaction between
different hosts for example animals
and humans can be particularly dangerous
and so one of the questions that we can
ask is how
do these pathogens change when they go
between different environments
one of the key issues here though is
that viruses
are not even alive in a traditional
sense
so the sequencing data an additional
aspect of the sequencing data
is really leading us to ask very basic
questions about pathogens
so we know that the way we categorize
life is actually divided up into three
large domains bacteria
archaea and eukarya and under this
classification system viruses are not
even a part of
the tree of life so they're certainly
not alive
in the classical sense because they're
not capable of
metabolizing or replicating on their own
but at the same time we cannot just
classify them as inanimate
because they are built of biological
molecules and contain genetic
information
and so we see that they are in between
kind of being alive and dead and that
problem is changing the way that we
think of life in general so
it's really the study of infectious
diseases using
data is changing our understanding of
life
so there is a debate about how to
classify viruses and
specifically this debate recently has
been
kind of heating up because of discovery
of these extremely large viruses
such as pandora virus they're so
gigantic that they can be seen with a
light microscope and contain
more genetic information than some
bacteria and so it has been proposed due
to some
intriguing similarities in dna sequences
specifically in the gene that encodes
for an
enzyme called rna polymerase that such
large viruses
actually constitute a fourth domain of
life and so
here we can see some
joke or a funny version of the tree of
life where we have bacteria
eukarya archaea and then a fourth domain
maybe it even includes aliens so really
the
ability to sequence such information and
understand
what is going on in the real environment
where these pathogens exist is not only
changing
the translational aspects of antiviral
vaccine design and antibacterial
antibiotics and things like that
it's also changing our very basic
understanding of life
and the way that we can approach is
asking some of these
very fundamental questions so at this
point i'm going to pause
i'm going to make sure that we don't
have any questions so are there any
questions about what we've done so far
i wanted to make sure that those of you
that have joined the session for the
first time that you have already joined
our communities like
linkedin and facebook groups that beefs
have mentioned and for those of you that
are
already a part of this program that you
are starting to think about
some of the ways that you can use
sequencing data to answer
questions that either are basic or
translational
about the nature and the function of
these pathogens
and their interaction with the host so
are there any questions that i can
answer right now
okay so please keep in mind if i am
going through the slides and you have
any questions that come up
you can write down that question in the
chat box and we will
make pauses for such questions and
answers and you're free to
ask those questions either during that
time or before that time
so when we have a pause we can address
any of the questions that come up
so let's talk about next generation
sequencing what is next generation
sequencing
what kind of data does it produce what
can we do with that data
so the process of next generation
sequencing
is when we take a sample a biological
material for example spit
saliva and we can then sequence the dna
or the rna that is inside this
biological sample
the problem is that in between getting
the sequencing data and being able to
ask the questions we need to structure
the data and so we'll talk a little bit
about the process of
bioinformatics pipelines that allow us
to structure the data
and start making that data available to
ask specific
questions now the amount of such data is
increasing exponentially here you can
see
some information on viral sequences
and this information is located in a
couple of uh
locations for example we have the joint
genome
institute that hosts uh in by january
2018
uh we see here over 700 000
uh total viral sequences or over close
to 400
000 uh unique viral sequences so a huge
amount of data
over 13 000 complete annotated genomes
of different viruses and millions of
sequences
of viral genes and proteins so a huge
repository of data and the
important part of this is that this kind
of sequencing data
is available in both raw and processed
format so when we talk about sequencing
we'll talk about how sequencing is done
different formats of sequencing data
and remember all of this data is
accessible so all of these repositories
are
available for anybody to have access to
and in the context of the program
we'll have sessions where we actually
access this data
and we start asking questions of this
data using some of the analytical tools
that we will discuss here in a second
so there are several approaches to
metagenomic and viral sequences
sequencing targeted amplicon
and whole dna and rna and these types of
data produce
very different types of results that
we'll talk about in a second
so targeted amplicon sequencing you can
see that
they're here together is really asking
is really amplifying signal or
information
that is contained in specific regions
those regions could be designed for
a particular type of a pathogen or
they could be specific to a gene that
can help us
understand taxonomic relationship
when we talk about whole dna and rna
sequencing this is a completely
different approach that produces
different types of data that allow us to
try to reassemble what is in the data
either by mapping on a particular set of
references and looking at abundances
or trying to understand what novel
information might be there that we are
not
capturing from a reference database but
still could be assembled based on
an assembly of longer and longer pieces
of genetic information
because of the way that we observe that
those pieces connected together in a
number of different reads so we'll talk
about that in just a second
but these types of methods are used for
different types of purposes
for example you can see here an
application of
genomic sequencing to track viral
outbreaks for example if we already have
identified
what is this outbreak caused by what
type of a pathogen
we can amplify specific viral sequences
and then look for specific types of
changes in the viral genome let's take
one group of viruses a family of viruses
like coronaviruses
and we can start asking the questions
well how is
the data that we have in this type of
sequencing different from
a reference genome of that particular
family or
a member a species of those viral
families
now we can also look at all of the data
that is available
so sequence all dna or rna align the
reads to
a virus reference on multiple references
for example a whole database of
references
and we can now look at what's called
metagenomic next generation sequencing
which allows us to study all of the
genetic information
in those in that sample here you can see
some of the applications so
applications are detection of a specific
microorganism
detection of specific mutations or
changes in gene expression because of
antibiotic resistance being developed in
a group of viruses again if you think of
that community of viruses or bacteria
they are not a single identical member
replicated many times this is a
community that has some diversity
oftentimes one of those members
could become resistant and eventually
replicate
to cause resistance to be
sufficient for this the cells to not be
able or the body not to be able to deal
with them
we can also look at changes in the
microbiome
and those changes themselves could be a
result of a condition
or could drive the condition they could
increase
risk of susceptibility they could also
change the way that our body metabolizes
and deals with different types of
challenges
in the environment and we can also study
host response so we can look at
changes in transcriptomic or rna
sequencing
to identify genes and pathways expressed
as a result of infection
and in the course of infection as well
now this type of data is produced by
sequencing machines the sequencing
machines
include short read sequencers and we
will
primarily in this program deal with
short sequence data so this
includes short reads that are generated
from
the full genome or whatever sample we
have
and we also have what's called long read
sequencers so these
for example pac bio can be as long as
tens of thousands of nucleotides when we
talk about
short read sequencing they could be as
short as 30
nucleotides long so very very different
types of data
and the challenges and the type of data
that they produce
are also very different so let's talk
about that a little bit
when we have data coming out of the
sequencer
it comes in multiple types of formats
and we'll refer to these formats
in all throughout the program so three
formats that you have to remember at
this point
fast q which is information about
sequencing reads
and those sequencing reads will include
the actual sequence as you can see right
here
the length and also quality so
quality for each one of the characters
how
confident are we in the quality of that
particular nucleotide
fasta files are files that contain
references or full assembly so when we
talk about
a full genome we're typically going to
find that genome
as a sequence in a faster file
and then also importantly for the
references we will have
what's called the genome transfer format
so gtf file or gff file
these files contain information about
genomic elements so where do they start
where they
end and what do we know about them so
this is annotation
for the fasta file format what do they
look like
here's an example of a fasta file
you can see that the fasta file
typically contains the name
of whatever that file is about so this
is
a spot of terra fruit frugi peridot
isolate
sf9 scaffold 12 so scaffold is like
a piece of the full genome whole genome
shotgun sequencing
here you can see another example rabies
virus the complete genome if we look
at the fasta file from a human genome we
will see there
that file divided into chromosomes so
divided up into pieces
sometimes we can get a faster file with
multiple
genomic sequences and they will have
these kind of separators
between the actual sequences so this is
a fastq
file the fastq file contains information
about reads
so here we can see the read please tell
me
what is the length of reads that you
observe
in this fastq file
hint this number is in the file that you
see on the screen
so what is the number okay
excellent right so we're starting to
learn how to read these files
you're exactly right so here you can see
the read
itself and here you see length 160. so
just making sure that you guys are
paying attention
so when the process of sequencing
happens we take
genomic dna that dna is broken up into
short pieces and that could be
anywhere between 30 and 300 base pairs
this is an example for a specific type
of sequencing
but here then we have library adapters
that are placed in a flow cell these
flow cells
based on the machine can be of very
different sizes and so they contain
a lot of variation in the number of
reads that we can
sequence and then we have a this complex
chemical process of pcr breach
amplification to produce enough
material for the machine to be able to
read it and the way it
reads the machine reads the sequence is
by looking
at image analysis so we have different
colors for different nucleotides as they
attach
they are we can observe them and then we
have these images and that's where this
quality score is coming from the quality
score is from the analysis of these
images
to give us an insight into how clear was
that
signal so as a result we have this
long sequence as the process of
sequencing happens
we have these long sequences coming out
and the sequences are
in short pieces so when we get
fast q reads or fast q files out of a
sequencer like this
shotgun sequencing one of the major
challenges is to then
annotate to understand where did that
particular read come from
if we have a long sequence the sequence
is already assembled for example we're
looking at a particular pathogen and
using singular sequencing
the challenge is then to align to other
sequences and try to find
variation so here are the two main
approaches to analysis for these types
of data sets
one example for fast q files is
analysis based on mapping and
faster files is analysis based on
alignment multiple sequence alignment in
this example
to understand relationships here it's to
detect
variants so two different approaches and
we'll talk about them
in greater detail now when we have this
genetic sequence what is
the genetic or genomic sequence
uh what are the letters in there the
letters are called
nucleotides right what are some of the
letters that you know
that are in nucleotide sequences
all right excellent a t c
and g so we have four nucleotides these
four nucleotides
form what's called amino acid sequences
so really when we look at this kind of a
sequence
we can convert all right look
at nasios also knows the full name so
exon so we have here a lot of
people that have this down so you can
see here
that we have the nucleotide sequence and
then we
have these reading frames and there are
several options for these reading frames
so we can get different types of amino
acids
based on the changes that we observe so
a typical process
is to map these nucleotide sequences
into codons so who knows what are
codons
i'm sure that athanasios knows but maybe
other people know as well who knows what
are codons
all right so a combination of three
bases that code an amino acid bobby's
thank you
and athanasios yep okay so these are
triplets of nucleotides each combination
represents an amino acid so when we look
at the
changes in those nucleotides we're
expecting
different types of changes in the amino
acids
and so what you can see here is an
example of an analysis
where you have the nucleotide sequence
mapped
into codon so you will have a three
letter for each one of your letters here
so that means that these three make this
one
amino acid and this codon mapping
follows specific rules so we know what
the different types of
amino acids are coded by what types of
codons
and there could be a lot of variation
right so there could be a lot of
different changes
there now importantly when we think of
functional implication of a nucleotide
change
we are thinking about a nucleotide
change that produces a change in the
amino acid
and so there are multiple different
things that we can expect from those
changes
including a stop codon that will stop
the translation of the sequence
and it will be result in a shorter
protein
and also it could be a change in the
amino acid and that change could be
either
in a specific given position or it could
carry on
so we will have a deformed or a
completely changed
protein as a result okay so let me pause
here i see some questions
can you explain what is frame shift in
reading translated amino acids
well a frame shift means that as you can
see right here
just the reading frame and you can see
that
the result of different changes means
that
the sequence itself of amino acids that
are being produced could be changed
completely
so if you have a specific sequence and
you change one letter
that letter could change the way that
downstream reading happens or
it could stop it completely that's
called the stop codon
shift frame mutation means that it will
change the subsequent reading
of the nucleotide sequence leading
into different types of amino acids
so does that answer your question mona
all right so now we can think of
how can such a change
happen so one of the questions that we
can ask
is if we align all of these sequences
to each other and we observe some
differences for example here you can see
g and here you see t if i observe
such a change or if i observe such a
change in terms of the amino acid
sequence
it means that the protein that is being
produced from the sequence is different
this causes some potential change
in phenotype that phenotype could be
defined
in we're talking about viruses in its
ability to replicate in different organs
and its ability to enter cells from
different hosts
in its ability to be highly
transmissible
so transmit more effectively between
different individuals in a population
so it's a change in phenotype so
oftentimes the question that we can ask
when we do this multiple sequence
alignment is
what is the relationship between the
observed species
and their ancestors and the way that we
can visualize
the relationship is called a
phylogenetic tree so we can look at
the evolution the process of change over
time
evolution and we can ask the question of
how
are they interrelated and that
phylogenetic relationship
really means that we assume that they
have a common ancestor and that ancestor
then divided up into multiple branches
and claims eventually resulting in the
species that we observe so we can
reconstruct that phylogenetic tree by
using
multiple sequence alignment what type of
information can that give us
here you can see an analysis of multiple
samples of ebola viruses
so we have a number of sequences from
ebola viruses from gabon
liberia great britain and we can ask the
question
how do they excuse me how do they relate
to each other
so if that relationship is closer
so for example these are closer to each
other than these
and what is their relationship in time
so looking at the
x-axis we can consider evolutionary time
the process of getting such information
from
sequencing data is alignment
conversion to amino acids and then
what's called a phylogenetic
tree reconstruction using multiple
sequence alignment
based on multiple types of models and
we'll talk about that in greater detail
sometimes we're not interested in the
relationship itself but we are
interested
in a particular change a polymorphism in
the case of
a population or a variant in the case of
a specific genome
and that mutation or exchange can
characterize a particular group of
samples for each individual sample now
importantly this type of an analysis is
based on
alignment of reads to the reference
genome so we can have this is an example
of a single sample
the single sample is aligned to the
reference genome
and if it is aligned to the reference
genome we can very confidently
identify some changes because they are
present in multiple reads
if they are present in all of the reads
we will have high confidence for example
here you can see a change
in this position we have one two three
four
five changes we don't have any other
data that will
indicate otherwise
well i wouldn't say that this is a new
virus this is some kind of variant
that emerges because most of the
information is the same
right so if we have um a lot of
similarity
that means that it is the same virus
it's just
developing new adaptations if it
if we see a lot of these and i'll give
you several examples here in just a
second
we can say that maybe it's a new virus
completely so
we'll we'll talk about that in just a
second
okay yes so important terminology here
haplotypes
when we say a new virus we need to
define
if we're looking at different levels of
taxonomy species family phylum etc so we
can talk about that as well
we'll talk about all of these concepts
but right now what i wanted to mention
is just
where the data is coming from and what
type of information are we getting
out of this data so in this particular
example
we are seeing a change a substitution
based on alignment to a reference and
what i wanted to point your attention to
is that some of these variants have
more confidence than others for example
in this case
we have two sources of data one read
and another read they do not match to
each other
and they do not match to the reference
genome if they don't match
that means that we have low confidence
it could be a result of a technical
error
so most of the time this type of change
is not going to be reported
this type of change will be reported as
a variant
and then sometimes we also can have
multiple regions or multiple letters
uh inserted or deleted if we have such
indication these are called indels so
different types of analysis
one of the primary ways to characterize
such data is what's called
variant calling and when we say vary i'm
calling it's to distinguish between
variants like this and all the other
types of variants that we have
low quality of information about and we
can think about
how to compare samples or groups of
samples
to understand whether such a variant is
present in
all of the samples from a population or
just a few
so a lot of questions that could be
asked here let's take a look
at a specific example
so here you can see a
collection of reads so each one of these
lines
is a read mapped onto
a reference genome okay so
what is this reference genome this
referent genome is called
beta coronavirus wuhan
uh wuhan institute of virology04 2019
ii okay so this is the code name
this is where it came from it's a beta
coronavirus sequenced
in wuhan you have all these reads
and these reads are aligned to some
reference now that does not mean that
these reads came specifically from this
virus you just take a sample
and you're saying okay let me align it
to this specific
type of a reference
you will also have a consensus a
consensus
talks about the majority of the
nucleotides
from the aligned reeds and they could be
very different
from the reference that we are using for
alignment we're just using this
alignment to kind of give it
a framework to follow as a result
we can get multiple types of genomes
assembled genomes and these assembled
genomes
could have specific variations that help
us characterize
those haplotypes or completely new
viruses
right so in the case of this coronavirus
we can talk about these are samples from
bats
these are samples from humans these are
samples from china these are samples
from usa
and this is how they are related to each
other by these specific mutations
by these insertions and deletions or by
these
sections that are completely different
right so then we can start asking
different questions
about how they are related to each other
and what could that mean functionally
so to kind of give you an insight into
all of this practically
we have this multi-omics platform that
we will use
in this program so in the program
we will not only speak about these
examples we'll actually do these
examples
together so when we talk about the
specific
samples or the specific sequences and
how they relate together
we will do some analysis so before i get
to your questions here in just a couple
of minutes
let me give you an overview of the types
of
bioinformatics analysis pipelines so
here what you can see is an example of a
pipeline
how these analysis pipelines could be
done on the t bio info platform
to identify phylogenetic tree
reconstruct the phylogenetic tree
to measure gene expression variation
between groups of samples
to align genomes to a reference to call
variants structural alignment
which will give us an insight into what
does this alignment mean
and varian call so detect variants that
are specific to a group of samples that
are different
between each other
so in this program we will talk about in
different sessions
about sequence variation evolutionary
relationships
functional inference from such
difference and the response from the
host
and that gives us a good overview of
host pathogen
interaction but we will go into other
examples as well
so let's talk about how we can do
alignment
multiple sequence alignment so let's go
to the platform please follow with me
to server dot t dash bio
dot info and i hope that this will also
give you
uh some answers to some of these
questions
okay so this is the link
please let me know once you are here
okay for those of you that do not have
an account yet you can easily click
on this access button and request a
demo account for those of you that do
have access
you should have received an email this
morning or last
week if you register depending on when
you register to get access to this
platform we will
use this platform extensively throughout
this
course and we will talk about how
you can analyze also data that you find
on your own to process and to analyze
this data
all right if you arrived here and you
are
logged in please please put in one
in the chat box so we know how many of
you are already here
i'll just give it a couple more minutes
so that all of you are here
all right excellent thank you very much
so again what we will do
is alignment of sequences just to
understand
what will that look like so here you can
see
phylogenetic tree and we will
also use this section and we'll do this
here today just so that i can talk about
some of these other ways to
study data from here so please go with
me
under virus quasi species even though
the same methods are available
in phylogenetic tree we'll look at virus
quasi species
and we'll go to this first demo virus
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic
analysis
so here you can see a combination of
multiple types of
use cases for different types of data
for example
you can start here and analyze data
using multiple sequence alignments the
multiple sequence alignment is done on
faster files you have to have
assembled sequences you already know
what the full sequence is
you want to align them to each other so
multiple sequence alignment
essentially aligns the different
sequences that you have
and here you can see some examples of
different types of beta corona viruses
aligned to the wuhan reference
sequence and then convert them to amino
acids that have different
physical chemical properties that we
will talk about
you can also analyze how the different
types of codons you can see that
each change could be a result of changes
in different positions in the codon so
we can look at the different
preferences over which positions we are
incorporating
and then we want to reconstruct a
phylogenetic tree so we'll look at
phylogenetic trees coming from multiple
methods these multiple methods will
produce small
variations or significant variations in
how the relationship is organized
and how the time the evolutionary time
is reconstructed so we can click on the
tree space to study the variation
between different results
and then let's click on end
and you will see here download pipeline
output files
okay so how many of you were able to
create this pipeline
if you were able to create the pipeline
please put number two
in the chat box
all right thank you ruthie
anita
alright so for amy again i'm showing
here on the screen you go from start
multiple sequence alignment multiple
sequence alignment a
a select codon position msa
and then all phylogeny methods tree
space and end
all right so you can review the video
afterwards and
try to replicate these steps the
important part of this
is that you should get some of these
demo
example results so here you can see
multiple pdfs these pdfs are going to be
of the phylogenetic tree
and this phylogenetic tree is produced
by four different methods
four different models or three models
for beast and one model for
eight you can also see a final
kind of uh tree and you can also see
the actual output table which aligns all
of the data
but does not tell us how it's related
just an alignment
importantly we can visually interrogate
such data so this specific output right
here
you can open it in excel but it's a
fairly large data
file and we'll talk about how to deal
with these data files
but i want to briefly visually
illustrate
what this data contains in terms of
information
so please go to me go with me to this
link
this is the direct output from what we
just saw
it's a sequence navigator that we
developed to visualize such
data and will give us a sense for how
these different types of
sequences are related to each other so
the data set i'm going to be using
is this one comparison of the birth
death coronavirus
so you don't even have to follow along
necessarily right now
just as long as you know that that
output file could be visualized in such
a way
what we see here is how
thousands of nucleotides so this whole
reference sequence is about 30 000
nucleotides long for the beta
coronavirus or for the sars coronavirus
about 30 000 nucleotides all together
when we align the reference uh when we
align all of these samples to the
reference
all these are faster files to the
reference
we can observe how many positions are
changing
from the reference in a bin so here we
can
change between bin sizes for example 250
or 500 nucleotides
and we can start seeing that some of
these are significantly different
from the reference so the more red they
are the
less gray they are the more different
they are from the reference
and we can identify whole sections on
the genome
that are significantly different in a
given
protein producing gene so here you can
see
a gene that is not protein coding
and here's the gene the blue one that is
protein coding
this gene happens to be the surface
glycoprotein or the spike
protein the spike protein and we'll talk
a lot more about the spike protein
is responsible for cell binding to the
cell receptors
and entry of the virus into the host and
we can see that there's
a lot of variation in this gene
between the different groups of samples
now these groups of samples are
organized by
the type of coronavirus that these
samples represent beta coronavirus
covin19 sars and myrrh so obviously
sars grove too and we can see that which
according to what you see in this
visualization which group
is the most similar to the novel
coronavirus that
causes cognitive so which other group
mers sars or beta coronavirus
is the closest to
this virus that causes copper 19.
okay so a beer is saying mers
any other guesses
again the question is which group of
samples
is the closest to this group of samples
right here for covert 19
based on sequence similarity okay so amy
is saying
sars anita is saying sars athanasius is
saying beta coronavirus
is saying sorry okay so again gray
means it's identical so you can see this
is zero
changes from the reference genome
so here we see all of these are gray
probably leads us to think that the
reference that we're using here
is a beta corona virus or the source
code ii genome
now we see here this group sars
has the least differences right these
are zero differences so whole
sections are actually identical to here
and some of these contain a smaller
number so smaller in the tense
if we go over to the mirrors this has
hundreds
of changes this has
hundreds of changes so it's obvious if
you look at this image
that sars is the closest to code90 and
that's why
stars cove two is closely related to
service code one
which is this section right here we can
visualize the way that they are
interrelated
by building a phylogenetic tree so this
phylogenetic tree you can see it's
annotated
beta corona viruses murst cova 19
and sars and you can see that this clade
right so this and this
represents a common branch from the main
phylogenetic
tree for covet 19 and sars so sars one
and stars two are the closest to each
other
based on a comparison between these
different types of viruses
does anyone have any questions about
this
all right if you have any questions
please post your questions in the chat
box and we'll address them
in just a second the second type of
analysis that we'll briefly describe
is variant calling different types of
data remember that this is
fast queue files not fast uh files right
and here the objective is to identify
specific positions that are very
different
from the reference genome and these
could be a result of selective pressure
variants and mutations that are
associated with a phenotype
so let's take a look at an example here
we have
the ebola virus so we can ask two
different questions
from this data one question is
let's visualize this data okay so
if we visualize the data we are
expecting
to see something that looks like this
and here we will find specific mutations
specific positions in multiple samples
that all agree that there's a change
from the reference
genome so somebody previously had a
question about
reference or sorry coverage
right here in the gray you can see the
coverage right here on the bottom you
can see the actual
reads so if we just visualize our data
we can look at the reads but we can also
ask well
altogether how many reads are aligned to
each position
which gives us a lot of different
confidence measures
for how we can be confident in a
particular change
so if we do variant calling we can
identify specific proteins
that have very defined mutations in
groups of samples
these groups of mutations can help us
characterize changes
in the protein structure and function
and if we find those changes
they could be critical for design and
development of vaccines
because we know that vaccines are only
as good
as the type of a virus structure that
they represent
so that's an important thing to remember
we'll talk about that
in a lot more detail in the future
now we some the question here doesn't
matter which tree
building method is used here obviously
that does matter
let's take a look at what these trees
actually tell us so here's an example
with ebola virus again and let's go to a
website called
next strain i'm sure that most of you
have probably
already heard about it so next strain is
a place where you can look at different
types of relationships
based on data and
and some information about what this
data represents in terms of
where it was collected etc so you can
see that there's a repository here on
source code too
other types of viruses tuberculosis
ebola vaccine or so sorry ebola
viruses etc so here you can see a number
of different resources
and we can go to this link for
ebola virus okay and this is a community
project
from a variety of um
a variety of um
groups that have collected samples from
different locations
in the 2013-2016 west african ebola
epidemic so this tree that you see
represents the diversification
of the viral genomes as
the virus spread between these different
locations
okay so if you just play this animation
it shows you
how samples from different locations
and the associated number of deaths or
infection
from these different types of in
different locations
has caused a change in the viral
sequence now if you scroll down here
okay let's do reset you can see
in which proteins on the reference
genome
did these mutations accumulate so let me
ask you a question
out of all the proteins that you see on
this reference genome
which protein do you think
has the highest diversity measurement
this is the y-axis the diversity
measurement so which protein
has a position that is the highest in
terms of
its diversity
okay so muhammad is saying sgp
so this is sgp right here anyone else
all right so uh some of you think sgp
some of you think
l i think l is the correct because you
can
see here if you hover over it says
uh entropy 0.357
okay here you see the entropy 0.285
so 0 3 5 7
is more than zero two eight five
so the correct answer is three nineteen
and here's
three eight five so three five seven
right so this is the highest one
the elk protein yep
it is difficult to see but this just
gives you some insight
into how important it is to
select the correct data and the correct
analysis
for what you are trying to do so again
if you play this
and you pause it
this changes right so where you sampled
and how much data you have this is this
window within this window
your results could be completely
different so some of you mentioned
sgp nobody really mentioned np but you
can see that
in this case this position is the
highest
in vp35 and so at this point in time
what was known is that the difference
between these groups
was best characterized by mutations in
this position
in this protein so you might have
thought okay well this protein is the
most important
as you continue playing this and you
pause in a different moment in time
that information will change so here np
is the highest
right so really the data is only
is very critical for the analysis and
for
interpretation that we will do so this
is just an example but i think
also it's important to remember the
significance of the data
the type of data and the type of
analysis so we'll talk a lot more
about the ebola virus these particular
mutations that we are observing
the types of analyses that we can do
with what kind of data
and even discover haplotypes and not
just the specific
mutations but actual haptical types that
are different
and we'll talk about the significance of
this type of viral diversity studies
that could be
an impact on the phenotype on how fast
the virus spreads
how severe is the disease that it causes
and what are the
results from such studies that have an
impact on antiviral drug design
and vaccine design any questions
okay so we're already running out of
time so let me briefly introduce you to
two
other mentors for this program
uh dr harpreet kawar and dr mohit
mizundar
will help you get the most out of this
program
so uh we will have a number of
practical exercises running these types
of analyses
analyzing the data in r looking
at the relationships between different
types of samples
and we will look at how you can develop
a project of your own so we will
see how these examples that we present
in the course of this program are really
designed to introduce you to
data repositories and analysis methods
for you to develop your own independent
methods and thinking about
bioinformatics analysis
so let me pass it on to dr harpreet kahr
she will just briefly introduce her
background
thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics
my research is on omics biomarker
discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
in my current role i am omics logic
bioinformatics trainer with pine biotech
i am looking forward to being your
mentor during this bioinformatics
for infectious disease program and help
all of you to learn about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
the application to large datasets
used in the biomedical research
especially
in infectious disease i will be happy to
assist
all of the participants in designing an
analysis
of the research project or any kind of
analysis so now i would
like to pass this session back to ilia
so
over to you india okay thank you
harpreet so again
we will have a number of technical
uh technical um sessions
where we will run analysis together look
at the results
and we will also introduce some of the
um
some of the uh examples in r
and uh uh and sorry harpreet
will be guiding those sessions and
answering your technical questions
so let me now pass it on to uh
dr mohit mazumdar who will talk a little
bit about
project mentorship
thank you india and hello everyone
my name is mazumdar and i'm one of the
global representatives of pine biotech
in my current role i'm working with
scientists and researchers and students
to assist with their omics big data
research
and collaborating with universities to
provide support for bioinformatics
training and education
bioinformatics for an infectious disease
is a special program
during this summer during this last
summer we had this
unique opportunity to work with experts
in data science
going 19 research ebola malaria
tuberculosis
and many uh life-threatening diseases
and where we
were trying to find answers to critical
questions
so during the last program we worked
with our participants
and throughout the program uh because of
that
that resulted in more than 50
independent bioinformatics research
proposals and projects so the projects
proposals were then
peer reviewed by experts and later
the video presentation was recorded by
our participants
on topics such as different versions of
human reference
genome in rna-seq analysis gr37 and gs38
and their influence on in-vitro studies
of kubit-19 drug test on human
organoids then another project was about
genetic predeposition to acquire a
polybasic cleavage site for highly
pathogenic h1n1 hematoglutin virus
so there were several uh research
proposals that we worked through
during that uh last during our last
program
so with this introduction i would like
to pass it on to ms beepsha
to take you further thank you uh thank
you so much uh dr mohit
for that overview and to elia as well
so before i start giving you all an
overview of the different resources i
wanted to talk to you all about what
omics logic programs are
so the goal of our omits logic programs
is to provide training
in bioinformatics enabling independent
research guided by mentors
and pure example developing a growing
community
with shared passion for data driven
research and appreciation of citizen
science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds
to develop novel and independent
research using
latest technology in life and data
sciences
in our omics logic programs we will
combine
online sessions self-guided study
materials
and practical assignments for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective
as you can see here so we will have
sessions like we did
today participants will have access to
courses
as well as we will be able to track all
kinds of participant progress
throughout this program
and i will shortly demonstrate this for
everyone
together with our collaborators we have
been building a growing online community
of buy information in training
ranging from high school students to
faculty and researchers
in top universities around the world our
team offers
big data analysis tools like the server
t by info platform
and the seek nav that we showed today
in programs designed to run various
topics
we discussed bioinformatics approaches
for processing
analysis integration and interpretation
of multi-omics data
from oncology neuroscience agrobiology
and infectious diseases
i encourage you all to sign up for free
on one of our portals and start
learning or teaching bioinformatics
it is one of the best ways we can
explore the world around us
at the molecular level with zero
equipment
or lab costs so now let us look at some
of the resources
that we will get as part of this program
i'm sure most of the participants
already have received an email from my
end
regarding the resources and also they
are familiar with it
so this is what we call our
bioinformatics
organization page for all of our
programs
so for the bioinformatics for infectious
disease program
this is your organization page
and here we will have the list of all
the events mentioned
so today we are on 9th november and we
have covered the topic of
next generation sequencing viral genomes
in host transcriptome
and we have answered questions we still
have
a lot of the questions in chat which we
will be answering
in a few more minutes and the next
session would be on multiple sequence
alignment
and phylogeny if you have not yet signed
up you can still sign up for this
program
and you see here in this page we will be
able to see
the progress and the activity of all the
members who are joining the program
now before i move on i want to show you
what a proof profile looks like so anita
i'm borrowing your profile for an
example
because anita here has a completed
profile
so if you are a participant or whether
you're joining us for the first time i
would request you to complete your
profile so what does a complete profile
looks like
it looks like this where you have a
profile image
and you have your full name mentioned so
when you sign up probably
this would just be your username so you
can change it via your profile
and using the edit button that you will
get after you click
on profile and you can also add your
social media links
so the profile is helpful because
as you saw that you know we collaborate
with our program participants
on different projects and then these
projects are also sent for peer review
so
this way members in our community will
be able to
learn more from you you would be able to
collaborate with each other
and even if you're not joining this
program you can still have the
opportunity to go out and explore
and talk and network with people in the
community so that is the reason
we would want you to have a complete
profile
and also having a complete name will
also be marked on your course
certificates
which you get after completing the
courses that are there
on the platform and now moving on
from the organization page we will also
be having access to the forums so as you
see here is a topic posted on the forum
called session recordings so this
session will again be posted there
so we will have various topics on
different
ideas where participants can communicate
with us
even beyond these live sessions
and then you have access to asynchronous
courses
so some of you may already have taken
the introduction to buying for matrix
course
and if you have not yet taken this
course please go ahead and take the
first basic course
which is free for everyone as is
introduction to genomics
so you will be able to find them as well
under here introduction to
bioinformatics
so all participants will have access to
these different
courses as well as projects so you see
here is one project on ebola
and as elia mentioned we will be
discussing these
in depth in the upcoming sessions
and for all participants we will be able
to see everybody's progress
right here on the tab so today as
everyone is joining
uh we do not have a lot of data from
everyone because we are just starting
the session today
but as we move forward we will be seeing
that there will be
several different graphs of these colors
where we will be able to track your
progress across all of our platforms
the pink uh is suggestive of
the codomix logic platform the
server platform is denoted by the grade
and yellow is for the courses and
activities that you do
right here and now moving on the other
things that the
participants will have access to is the
server t by info platform now i know
that a lot of people have in uh
requested
the demo access to the platform so the
demo access
to the server t by info platform will
only give you
access to demo pipelines you won't be
able to upload your data or do any of
the hands-on
analysis but all participants should
have access educational access to the
platform
and this platform is also available for
research access and if you need more
information on that
please email us at marketing at pine.bio
i'm just putting my email down in the
chat again
and harshit i'll just get back to your
question in one more minute
the other platform which elia also
mentioned a while ago
which was uh practicing in r
and python so we have courses on the
codemix logic platform
where participants will be able to
utilize this platform for a
browser-based
experience i'm sorry about this
browser-based experience
utilizing r and python for
training and learning from these data
sets that we discussed today and also
from other data sets
and also the seek nav which we had seen
today
so these are some of the resources that
are there as part of the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
and we'll of course talk about the other
resources like we mentioned
some of the public domain repositories
which we will be mentioning throughout
this program
and utilize those data sets for our own
projects and see how we can
learn about viral diseases and to answer
harshita's question
the training certificate okay so
harshita for the training certificate
we have a parameter which we call
getting 10 000 points so you do not
necessarily have to complete all of the
courses
listed there we hope you do and once you
have over 10 000 points i'll show
anita's so anita has been
in a few programs and she has over 24
000 points so she has received
uh certificates of excellence in the
past so
if you have over 10 000 points you
receive a certificate of excellence
if you have anything below 10 points we
give out a certificate of completion
we hope that you
uh go through the different resources
that are available
and the different courses which we make
completely available to you for the
program
so i have a question from mona right
here
the question is how to maintain our
membership
so we will be able to use these programs
beyond the
2nd of december to answer this question
very quickly
there are several membership options
that you can take
and i think that once we go to the end
of the program
we can send you the different links that
we have to the membership
options so that you can keep on your
access
to the different resources for the
program or the resources
uh to your access to the server platform
so each time you do uh complete a course
so the question is how much points do
each course carry so the points that
each course carry is 500 points
so once you complete a course you get
500 points and
getting to 10 000 is not at all
difficult
because you will not only be doing
courses you will be running pipelines
that gives you 50 points
again each of the pipelines that you run
as well as the codemix logic platform
will also carry points so it should not
be very difficult the only thing that
you would have to do
is keep on maintaining this and doing
the courses at your own free time you
don't have to do it
along with us but you can do it at your
own free time during this one month
program
and utilize these different resources
now
i would want to pass this on to elia
elia back to you
thank you very much biebsta uh so as you
saw we presented here
what we can learn about
viral and bacterial pathogens by
analyzing their genomes
we talked a little bit about next
generation sequencing which is key
to this kind of ability to analyze and
ask questions of the data and we talked
a little bit about some additional
resources that if you see
gaps in your knowledge for example if
you
are not familiar with some of the
terminology that we use today you don't
understand the reads you don't
understand coverage you don't understand
how this data is prepared
we ask you to use some of the
synchronous resources to
catch up and be ready for this program
some of the data sets that we will
analyze are fairly big
so you will see data sets that are
gigabytes in size
and hundreds of megabytes in size to
analyze
and process all of this data on your own
computer can be
prohibitive just because of the size of
memory and
cpu and your pipelines will just take
forever so
to make this program go faster we've
prepared this
online resource called the t-biome for
platform we'll also introduce you
very quickly to advanced methods of
analysis you don't have to wait
and build the pipeline the pipelines are
already pre-built
the results are already informative as
you will get them
and then finally this community that we
have allows you to interact with
mentors peers work together on projects
ask questions make sure that you start
getting into the more interesting and
advanced questions much faster
so what we'll do in the next several
sessions is go over
sequence analysis alignments
phylogenetic trees
analysis of genomic and transcriptomic
data and you'll start seeing
how some of these publications that talk
about viral
phylogenetic relationships uh resistance
to
antibiotic drugs and also
relationship with the immune response
and disease progression could be
answered
using data sets that are already
available on
ncbi and other publicly available
resources
for those of you that have already
joined the program
i have an assignment so for those of you
that are just joining and you're still
not familiar with
many of the terms that we're using we
ask you to complete introduction to
bioinformatics actually this is also for
those that are joining for the first
time
and you just want to try one of these
courses this is a course that is free
you can complete it in probably under
one hour
and what it has is an overview of
different types of
important terms and concepts and how
bioinformatics is used across
a wide range of applications
importantly it also has a survey
that helps us learn about you and
propose some meaningful
coursework or programs that are upcoming
so really
a way to personally address some of the
interests that you might have
this type of material has been reviewed
by
faculty undergraduate and graduate
students and all of them agree that this
information even though it might seem a
little bit introductory
is useful even if you are a professor
or a researcher and especially if you're
a student
so it's an introductory course but can
provide an
interesting level of detail we also ask
you if you're already done with
introduction to bioinformatics
to complete a course on metagenomics
this will give you some
insights into what types of data
could be extracted from sequencing data
we have a course called introduction to
metagenomics
which again is free or metagenomics one
if you're a part of the programmer
and for a project we ask you to look
at spot update for geperda which is a
project that allows you to
analyze sequencing data and detect
a novel pathogen to characterize it
and understand why it might be important
for
a biologic's production pipeline
for biotechnology companies so again
your assignment
is to look at spot-uptera fugiperita
complete introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to metagenomics or
metagenomics one
and also we have a blog post that talks
about virology resources for those of
you that are interested
in virology and how to analyze virology
data
please take a look at this blog post
that will allow you to
explore some of the databases and some
of the tools that are available
in these different uh repositories so
this is the link
to here
okay um let me answer some of the
questions that i've seen here
okay so the question could you reference
tb info platform is used in publications
yes
we have a whole link to a list of
publications for different
algorithms many of the algorithms used
on the platform that our public domain
have been used extensively on a variety
of different
projects so we have a list of those
publications we'll be happy to send you
a detailed view
of uh what it does
so please email us marketing
at pinebio and we'll get back to you
with any additional questions i wanted
to
summarize by sharing
a profile of someone who is
successfully completed the project and
some of the feedback that we got from
that person because i think
many of you might be wondering what is
the difference between this program
and some of the other online programs
that you might get in data science and
bioinformatics
maybe in molecular biology or virology
so i think that what we've seen
is that many of the activities combined
together
really develop in an experience that is
not similar to many of these programs
we don't take just general concepts and
go through
the methodology we guide you
on how to ask questions about data and
answer them
using analytical tools the objective of
the program
and for those of you that really want to
succeed in the program is really to
develop an independent project
so there are several reasons why you
might choose to
be a participant in the program and
benefit from all of these resources
together
the analytical platform the coding
platform
the educational asynchronous courses and
the interactive sessions that we will
have
and so beeps has just posted a link to
this blog you can
go through the blog and just kind of see
some of the uh
reasons why um the people that really
benefit from the program have joined and
how it's different from some of the
other online resources
also we are whether you're a part of
this program or not a part of this
program we welcome you to join
our groups on linkedin and facebook we
post their regularly resources
free data sets example projects
as well as opportunities for career
development
on these groups so if you are a
budding bioinformatician or you're an
expert in the field
we want to be connected in the long term
so please join our
groups on social media that will help us
stay in touch
and i do want to mention that this
program is going to continue
for the next um several sessions
we will have um a special recording of
this session made available and we'll be
happy to share with you if you've
already registered with an email
and i'm happy to answer any final
questions before we finish this session
okay well if there's no questions right
now i was
excited to get started with this program
and hope to see
all of you join us again next time thank
you for
registering and we are looking forward
to working with you on developing your
own independent bioinformatics projects
in the next few weeks um we'll have this
recording shared with you by email
anyone that wanted the materials you can
review that in your own time
and if you have any additional questions
please feel free to reach out to us
again marketing at pinepipe dot bio
thank you again and we will
see you again next time